let's now go to Stockholm and what has
really been this is the the most heavily
foreign policy related and foreign
international news related show we've
done in a very long time Pat perhaps of
all time perhaps of all time I agree
with you four people were killed and at
least a dozen were injured in Stockholm
Sweden on a pedestrian street when a
truck smashed into a store it is being
called a terror attack one man has been
arrested there's a lot of video
circulating from the incident and in
response the Swedish Prime Minister has
strengthened border controls we've
learned that the truck belonged to the
Swedish brewery spend resettling on its
way to a restaurant delivery earlier in
the day quote from the brewery someone
jumped into the driver's cabin and drove
off with the vehicle while the driver
was unloading shots were reportedly
fired in another part of the city but
Swedish police told local media that
there was no connection between the
incidents a man has been detained a 39
year old man from Uzbekistan who was
arrested the man was reportedly listed
for deportation several months ago quote
in December 2016 he was informed by the
migration agency that he had four weeks
to leave the country two months ago the
case was handed over to the police to
carry out the order and since then this
man went quote underground on April 9th
the Swedish police chief confirmed that
the man showed interest for extremist
organizations like Isis these attacks
are helpful to Donald Trump in a few
ways particularly since little attention
is being given to them number one this
occurred and coincided almost perfectly
to make entire remember Donald Trump's
look what happened in Sweden thing and
of course at the time nothing had
happened in Sweden Sweden hadn't
experienced a sort of legitimate terror
attack since 1986 and now within just a
few weeks this happens it is very
convenient for Donald Trump and number
two this helps to draw negative
attention away from the constant Russia
situation and again I said it earlier
and I'll say it again the bombings in
Egypt
the serious strikes what we're seeing in
the Korean Peninsula this attack in
Stockholm to the to the extent that it's
getting corporate media coverage and
it's not getting much because of so much
else going on this all foment spat an
environment that is much friendlier to
beating the drums of war we know this we
know this from experience and this is
why we have to be extra vigilant when we
read that for example of the 20
newspapers that wrote an editorial about
Syria strike 17 were partially or
completely in favor of those strikes
yeah it was a tough weekend in the world
that's for sure and with all these
tragedies going on there's this natural
reaction to do something about it yeah
but honestly what we end up doing could
make the situation perhaps the region of
the Middle East in a far worse shape
than where we came in
no doubt about it and when we're paying
attention to the specific claims that
are being made by people in the
administration to justify redirecting
that naval a group of ships from
Australia to the Korean Peninsula or
threats to Syria or whatever the case
may be we have to make the effort to
separate ourselves from the visceral
reactions that are designed for us to to
feel as a result of the media coverage
that we see we spoke to UMass professor
Michael Morgan about this about the
impact of reporting on these types of
issues and and it has a predictable
impact on making us see the world as
less safe even if statistically the
world is safer than it's been in a very
very long time measured in a number of
different ways we've got to keep our
heads on and not conflate all of these
different stories today's episode of the
David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS